okay slow G was a girl katate dori
[Music]
I check Vance your art why are you
waiting there
[Music]
change your height you can change this
can take techniques
[Music]
but say that saying that blinds lock
word from the blind spot what else
okay let let it let it tell you where to
go okay what so eternal right and the
end the a huge automations and then of
course this to do all this to don't
predict i can't have any and
neutralization if i'm thinking okay so i
I do this by doing all of that adored
about Center connections you know I
already have that yeah okay this is what
you're doing this sensor
[Music]
just strike and then what I took
your base okay
deconstructed faces do you guys know
like this I mean you're not penetration
you could just go like this happen so
[Music]
change
you got too much throwing desire
get you other side of the line someone
shot your arm with fertilizer Dart
[Music]
so that's that's a you're not there
it's not here
here we tell it if you see it okay then
then you kid don't don't look for the
thrill look for the connection no we saw
you see find the connection
yeah
[Music]
so you're you're prioritizing that's
rough prioritize the center the center
connection feeling the IE key okay once
you're Nike you don't have to throw
right away okay go
see it's not there that's gonna be a
leverage throw those are all leverage
throws
[Music]
you use your whole body to keep the
connection everything is working in the
same way that's aiming into a center
this is aiming into a center but so is
my body my body is so you guys look
you'll get in this these positions a lot
but you don't have your body but your
body aims
[Music]
so when you bring it bring it to the
body with the body like he's all
together not out here like this
that connection is what I want this deal
it by releasing it
okay so there is okay so the concept
here is don't go for that because all
these other things
okay so instead you want to attack these
things as you're going in mind and think
of a tackle or is neutralizing sometimes
senior to myzel but maybe maybe god
maybe I want some utilize oh so I'm
gonna take my elbow okay so instead of
coming to cheer like that maybe I hit
the elbow right cool and I come up and
do that all right
or maybe he thought he draws that again
right I moved out on cool when I came
inside that that legging neutralize out
and you see now now there's a good space
there and now you can come up and attack
that spinal ring okay got the concept
okay you're doing it in your weapons to
be what's not going to really require as
much investment okay so here you are
you're doing your to you Oz up and when
he knows
the other thing is he's been hit a lot
okay a terrible at my hands of either
Jason but my house both leaders okay but
the case will that are scared of the
hallway and IP sensation when they loose
control in a drone where there's no
striking he were just working slow she
was uh they will disconnect you
understand so he I'll come in and he
goes and I feel that I felt am going to
my son I'll do that
you see I'm good I take my Center I'm
gonna technique what you can do is you
can get their balance in your room you
get you can get their balance in such a
way and he he does not want to go down
so he's lifting up on my hand well that
gives me back we said so I take one fear
against down and usually the game set
under here you see that so it's gonna go
like this and you're all like I'm you
just disconnect I wouldn't try to and
he'll push back at me you see that is
one way okay and that was a great way of
just learning the concept of dilemmas
right just like thing there was a I'm
going to give you a dilemma you're going
to go one winner of the other okay and
then we have a lot the other thing is
remember I said they can neutralize it
so she just sushi she came back here
when I got her a little off-balance
right but she will turn to neutralize it
and you should because the spiral ring
is way more control than the arms so
when your connection still travels down
the leg so I'm not gonna like that
nice come here you see it's still in the
center
she gives me back that hand every was
there it is right there to see there it
is
so I then I can't get it gone
so when you when you feel the arm go Ted
come up to the head and now that would
happen it's not poking oh it's seven
connections that she gave me back the
hangers just following you see and she's
right here on me right here you see
she's trying not to fall oh so don't be
damn nothing right you could do it all
day but try to see the difference not
Center
Oh
okay just say think just like the wrist
go many plates irony is better